en un témoignage maintenant un
témoignage sur la guerre du sierra leone
en afrique témoignage exceptionnel car
il s'agit de celui d'un ancien enfant
soldat
forcé de s'enrôler il a pris les armes à
12 ans comme beaucoup d'autres il s'en
est sorti aujourd'hui il raconte
philippe rochot catherine juste ismaëla
leur regard timide d'un jeune étudiant
africain qui découvriraient paris et
pourtant ismaël à tuer de sang froid
quand il avait 12 ans enrôlé de force
par l'armée de sierra leone son pays
quand ils nous en rôle dans la guerre
ils ne font pas attention à nos c'est un
procédé perd on ou fausses
et si vous dites non je n'y vais pas il
voulait à l'époque en 92 le front
révolutionnaire de sierra leone tout
comme l'armée recrutait de force des
enfants de la chair à canon à bon marché
ismaël a dû tuer sous l'emprise de la
drogue et la menace de ses chefs
il revoit dans ses rêves ses images de
combats je n'oublierai jamais ce qui
s'est passé durant cette guerre havana
nights faire des cauchemars revoir des
images d'horreur c'est finalement un
petit prix à payer à mes yeux parce que
beaucoup de gens n'ont pas survécu
ismaël évacués aujourd'hui ses angoisses
d'enfants soldats dans un livre où il
raconte son chemin il n'oublie pas que
250 mille enfants dans le monde sont
obligés comme lui de prendre les armes
et de tuer récupéré par l'unicef puis
évadé de sierra leone
il a troqué son uniforme de soldat
contre la veste cravate et fréquente les
conférences internationales
il est écouté par rama yade secrétaire
d'état aux droits de l'homme
il est devenu le porte parole des
enfants soldats le plus efficace serait
qu'il n'y ait plus de guerre a gardé
qu'une guerre commence quelque part les
enfants sont tout de suite enrôlé plus
dur est de trouver une volonté politique
ismaël aide aujourd'hui l'unicef a
réalisé un vaste programme de
rééducation pour ceux qui faisaient la
guerre en culottes courtes mais une
bonne vingtaine de pays recrute encore
de force des enfants pour leurs milices
ou pour l'armée
toujours à l'étranger